i need a haircut
what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to another one of these
kind of
weekly vlog slash devlog slash i'm still
trying to figure out what these videos
are
basically for those of you who are new
to this because this is a relatively new
thing i've done like once in my life
i thought it would be a cool idea to
have like a little bit of a weekly
devlog where i show what i've done in
hazel specifically the development
branch of hazel which is like the 3d fun
version that i'm continuously working on
and live streaming and doing all that
stuff and treating that as more of like
a general update of
everything that's been going on not just
specifically hazel dev so welcome to the
weekly vlog
i am indeed wearing this jumper it seems
like it's the only thing i
wear these days i'm sure this is going
to become a meme or something
let's talk a little bit about what's
happened over the last week and what is
new
i hate my hair i really don't it's just
a ball of fluff man
what's going on video was going so well
too but it's a complete disaster anyway
so you guys are gonna have to bear with
the hair today because it's just having
a bad hair day
so a few weeks ago i started doing
weekly live streams where i showed
myself working on hazel dev and all of
the kind of new stuff that i was
implementing it's meant to be like a
really chill stream
where i just work on hazeldev as i would
but it's just completely live streamed
this idea
originated from a few things first of
all it was a suggestion by some people
second of all i wanted to figure out a
way to reward patrons more
and third i really needed to find a way
to actually
discipline myself to like sit down and
work on hazel death because with so many
things going on like amongst making
videos and all that it was difficult for
me to sometimes find the time to
actually sit down
and work on hazel dev but if it's kind
of like a you know
weekly stream for patreons like it
obviously it's something that i'm
actually going to sit down and do
and reflecting back on how it's gone
because this is kind of like a new thing
that i introduced in april
i really enjoy it i'm definitely going
to keep doing it
and to be honest i think i've done more
work this month for hazel than i have or
for hazel's dev specifically than i have
like this entire year and i think part
of the reason is that when you sit down
in front of a live stream and you start
doing well pretty much anything
like work related you know you're going
to probably keep working on it for the
duration of the stream
like i can't just start working on hazel
dev then as soon as something becomes a
little
a little bit difficult or a little bit
hard i just kind of give up and start
watching youtube videos if i'm on stream
that's never going to happen i'm going
to sit down and i'm actually going to
work out the problem and i'm going to
solve it
that's something that you don't really
get when you just work by yourself so
i've been really appreciating that kind
of environment it's also cool to have
people kind of
you know watch you and comment on
everything you've done
because obviously you know i'm i make
mistakes and it's good when someone's
kind of watching you and being like oh
you forgot this or you forgot that or
you misspelt something or you use the
wrong
value or wrong number here and that's
why it's not working so it's been
really cool it's also been really cool
to interact with the community more and
i've just really loved that i've
mentioned several times that kind of
working at home and not being in a team
in like an office is kind of a new
change for me still
i'm still getting used to it i'm i still
don't really like it because i'm a very
social person so i think these live
streams
uh have been absolutely amazing the
other really cool benefit is because the
streams kind of are recorded and there's
like a whole library of these streams
i'm going to be able to look back on
basically a lot of hazel's kind of 3d
development not just the game engine
series where i teach everything but
literally me for hours just sitting
there working
on hazel and figuring out all these new
things and making things and hazel
whatever it is that i'm doing
so i think that like it's i'm just
really happy with the live streams
i've finally got my home internet
upgraded to a decent upload speed so i
can stream in really high quality
and yeah i'm just super excited it's
been on my mind the whole week now i did
mention that it's for patrons only and
it is meant to be like a reward
for patrons supporting me and i totally
understand for those of you who can't
afford to do that especially at the
moment and i'm grateful for
all of you watching my videos no matter
if you're patrons or not and that's why
i'm going to be doing these weekly vlogs
i'm just going to show what i've done in
hazel and you guys can kind of get the
big picture
and still obviously follow the
development of hazel i keep saying like
hazel dev hazel 3d
i don't know hazel is one engine i'm
just kind of developing it in two
different worlds so to speak so if i'm
talking about like 3d or dev or whatever
then
that's referring to like hazel dev i
guess and then hazel itself i think i
might even refer to that just as the
game engine series because that's like a
completely different project if you
think about it
all together on one hand i'm building an
engine but on the other hand i'm
teaching people how to build an engine
those things are
kind of different anyway the point is
it's a new month
it's may i really want to share these
live streams with more of you so what
i'm doing
for this month is i'm completely slicing
the live streaming price in half the
previous patreon tier level to access
the live streams was the same as the
tier level to access the hazel dev
source code
which was ten dollars a month however
i'm reducing that to five dollars a
month so if you want to
watch these live streams it's just five
bucks a month i really think a lot of
you would enjoy it and of course i'm
super grateful for all of your support
i wouldn't be making hazel at all if it
wasn't for you guys so
thank you so much i love you all now
speaking of live streams last night i
was going to stream myself
making some music for the kind of hazel
boulder dash game that we made and we
talked about
in some of the previous episodes of the
game engine series and because making
music
is kind of different to programming and
because i also
like to stream myself playing minecraft
and i like to just hang out with the
stream and it's clearly not really
related to the content on this channel
i thought it would be a good idea to
make a new kind of personal
channel a channel that's kind of about
me not really about the churno
but more about just my life and the
stuff that i want to show maybe random
vlogs maybe you know
minecraft streams maybe like music and
music production streams and stuff like
that a channel that isn't necessarily
about the programming
software engineering side of me but just
is more about me as a person
and so i did that so i've got a new kind
of personal channel i'll leave a link in
the description below
last night i did a live stream on that
channel and that stream is gonna stay up
we basically just hung out and i did a
little bit of a q a session then i ended
up playing a couple songs for the stream
walk in your rainbow
paradise and then we played some
minecraft so all in all it was a cool
little chill stream we just hung out had
a good time
if you guys want to see more of that
then definitely head over onto that
channel and subscribe i've got quite a
few things in store for that channel
there's definitely not going to be any
kind of release schedule
but a lot of the stuff that you can
maybe expect on that channel is like
music cooking maybe a little bit of
gaming i'm not really
that into gaming aside from like playing
a little bit of minecraft every now and
then so we'll see what happens there
just random vlogs stuff like that so i'm
super excited about that but yeah again
no release schedule it's just whenever i
feel like putting stuff up that's more
personal
it will go on that channel now i've been
really excited
recently about the whole hazel boulder
dash kind of experiment and i've even
started making my own little thing
inside hazel it's really cool now that
people are able to use hazel even though
it is still very limited especially in
my eyes
people that's the community starting to
kind of take it and make stuff with it
and that's super important for
for the maturity of a game engine like
if there's no users making anything for
the game engine it's very very difficult
for you to actually make a good game
engine it's not even about
you making things it's about someone
else coming in who isn't you who hasn't
ridden the engine who doesn't really
understand how it works
definitely not as well as you to come in
and then start to actually use your
software use your architecture
to actually try and build something to
create something
that's really cool and it's very
beneficial to hazel and so one of the
things that really stops
hazel dash which is the name of the new
name of the boulder dash clone that
we've actually just taken and started
changing
one of the things that's stopping that
from actually being i guess a proper
game
because even though it doesn't have like
a scripting language and it might not
have this and that and hazel is still
missing so many things
it's still very possible to make a game
but there is one thing that's missing
and that is audio
without sound effects without music it's
kind of not feature complete
so to speak so last week over the course
of like a few hours i just wrote a
little audio library called hazel audio
which i'm
probably going to completely rewrite
over this weekend maybe
because i've i've you know having used
it for a week now i've realized that i
may want to do it a little bit
differently but we've integrated that
into the hazel dash game so now we have
like sound effects in it that's why i
was going to write some like background
music and stuff for it so that's been a
lot of fun and that's one of the things
that i've done this week and i'll
probably make a video
next week talking a little bit more in
depth about how that project is going
and sharing
a little bit more about that with you
guys as far as hazel dev goes over this
past week i've been mainly focusing on
the rendering side of it i've added msaa
multi-sample anti-aliasing
i've added uh basically better material
support and being able to kind of take
in fact i'll show you guys in a minute
one of the biggest next stages that we
have
aside from rendering because rendering
is something that i'm probably going to
keep working on like
you know over the course of hazel dev's
development because there's always more
rendering features
you can add there's always ways you can
kind of improve things make it support
more
all of that stuff but we need some kind
of scene slash entity component system
and that's one of the biggest things
that we're going to be focusing on in
the dev branch because if we can do that
and we can integrate lua you know then
we
finally have some kind of way to make 3d
games and hazel
without even using c plus plus and
that's kind of the dream and especially
since
hazeldev actually has a pretty good
editor set up that's capable of doing
all that stuff you know that's
definitely the steps in the right
direction not to mention the fact that
we'll be able to take that scene system
and that ecs system
and actually integrate that into public
hazel into the game engine series hazel
and since i would have already written a
good ecs and scene kind of system
inside hazeldev i'll be able to
obviously kind of teach that design and
integrate that back into the game engine
series so that's the kind of overall
plan there
that's what's going on with hazeldev
let's take a look at at the features
that i basically added this week
okay so as i mentioned this week was
primarily spent on
improving the rendering and graphics and
just i guess beginning scenes in general
in hazel
so what i did was i jumped into blender
i made this little test scene we have a
whole bunch of
actual different objects obviously that
make up this scene we have five objects
all together wall floor and then this
sphere cone
and cube what i did was i actually gave
each of these a material
in shader if we just look at like the
material preview for example and if we
jump over
into shading you can see that we have
different materials for each of these
objects
and we can easily just control all these
materials using
blender's material system now the idea
is that an artist working inside blender
should be able to basically construct a
scene
inside blender and then have hazel
render it
in essentially the same way i mean
obviously there are going to be
differences they are different renderers
but the data that we kind of set over
here inside blender
that should more or less be able to be
translated into something that you would
see
inside hazel so in other words if i make
a green cube a kind of blue cone
and a red sphere inside blender i should
be able to
export that and see that inside hazel
and that's basically the workflow that
i've been ironing out this week
so if we jump into hazel and we load
this model you can see that is
essentially what we see
we have all of these objects here you
can see that the roughness is also kind
of
translated from blender so inside
blender we might have this surface
having a roughness of one
having a metallic value of zero meaning
it's not a metal because it's in this
case it's basically like concrete
and then we should be able to jump in
and say that well okay let's maybe make
this a lot rougher
and let's change the color to what color
do we like here orange we like orange on
this channel
let's change the color to orange and
then theoretically we could just
export that as an fbx i'll maybe call it
test
scene video or something like that for
this video i'll hit export and then over
here in hazel i can just open the
test scene video here it is open and
then you can see that we have that kind
of new
material properties being imported here
and looking over here in our scene
hierarchy you can see that in this
example we've kind of got this gun
and then this scene i can look at the
test entity which is the scene it's got
a mesh
we have a root node and then we have all
of these kind of wall sphere cone
all of these various meshes that we can
actually explore within the scene
hierarchy and of course i'm going to
clean up the ui here and bring out all
of these
transforms and stuff into probably this
properties panel but you get the idea
and if we switch back to our original
scene one of the things that i think is
very important when you when you are
making a render especially if you're
trying to make a physically based
renderer
is making sure that what you're
rendering is actually correct so you can
see that i mean looking at this
we have this kind of halo around this
red sphere and that was throwing me off
a lot and this is the fresnel and the
fresnel is basically the the increased
reflectance that we see at grazing
angles
so along the edges of the sphere i mean
even in the real world if you hold
something up and you look at it from a
very kind of glancing grazing angle
you'll see that it's actually more
reflective than if you look at it like
straight on like this
which is why we should see that
obviously when we're rendering things
now in this case it looks particularly
amplified
and one of the reasons it doesn't look
amplified here does it it looks
amplified on top of this because this is
very dark
and it looks like this sphere obviously
is still reflecting the kind of bottom
and this is just a very bright cube map
it's a very bright environment but this
was throwing me off and i was convinced
for like a good half hour that the
the fresnel is just wrong which you know
is i guess pretty difficult because the
fresnel equation is actually very simple
which is why it's really important to
have a good reference and for that i
really like using a program called
marmoset tool bag it's something that
we used to use at ea and it's just
pretty much industry standard but if we
look at this same scene using marmoset's
renderer
you can see that well it looks the same
we see this massive kind of halo around
this thing and it ultimately looks very
similar to what it does inside hazel
hazel maybe looks a little bit less
more dull or less contrasty or whatever
that could be due to a number of
reasons but obviously all in all i'm
happy with this and you can see that
like the weird kind of cone reflectance
which is just due to the way that it's
modeled i guess
is kind of you know it's consistent with
what we see inside
hazel so it's important to compare your
renderer to other renderers
with kind of the same input material
parameters i'll say
to make sure that everything is running
okay and obviously you know
for this example as i mentioned a very
bright environment if i was to load a
different environment map by go into
assets
and then maybe what's a pink sunrise is
kind of a dark one
then you can see it looks completely
different because it's kind of dark you
know the scene is dark and this will
look different
so that's just one thing that had me a
little bit confused
earlier today now as i mentioned the
other thing that i added was
multi-sample anti-aliasing so you could
i think this is msa
msaa eight times at the moment but you
can see this line here
which is the wall looks very smooth
looks completely not jagged
at all so that's one of the reasons why
i wanted to add in msa in fact
everything looks super smooth all the
lines look
very smooth and not not jagged at all
which is really cool so
that was just something i've kind of
kind of just slapped in this view that
you're seeing here is now rendering into
a multi-sampled
frame buffer or rather a texture that
supports multi-sampling and then we're
multi-sampling to actually display that
again
onto this viewport so that's kind of the
idea and of course it
it massively increases the graphical
fidelity of our scene
i am obviously going to make that an
option we'll have the ability to disable
that and then probably do two times four
times eight times but that's something
that i will add in the future i also
added the 2d batch renderer into this
so we can actually render things in 2d
space on top here if we like
and to that effect as well i added
bounding boxes so if we toggle this show
bounding boxes or just hit ctrl b
you can see that it will actually show
us bounding boxes over all of the
objects in our scene
now at the moment doesn't work with
animated meshes which is why the gun
doesn't have it
but with static mesh as you can see for
each mesh here we have the ability to
view the bounding box we can also check
this on top checkbox and now it will
actually render them on top so if i'm
behind a wall
or anything like that i can still see
them and this is all done
using the 2d renderer so the 2d batch
renderer i've extended it to also be
able to render lines
and i've put it into hazel so we can
render quads and lines and all that
stuff
and these are obviously all bashed into
one draw call as well so those are
basically
the new features that i've added into
hazel over the last week or two but
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
little devlog let me know what you think
of these this is kind of
still a relatively new idea i'm i'm
hoping to be able to do these weekly and
just show you guys all the progress
that i've done obviously for me you know
being accountable and being able to show
stuff that i've done during the week it
it's it's helpful and it's healthy for
me to
kind of you know do that because i have
no boss and it's nice to be able to be
like hey guys you know
check out all the stuff i've done what
do you think does it look right to you
all of that stuff so thank you guys for
watching i do hope that you enjoy these
don't forget that you can help support
everything that i'm doing here on
youtube and hazel by going to
patreon.com
thank you so much for your support don't
forget about the new personal channel
that i've made if you are interested in
that
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you